you seem like a nice guy man I'm just
trying to give you I'm kind of giving
you hard time today
I love Lee gets meaning that he's very
polite southern hospitality
some people know if someone if you're
joking you know I don't know if you're
joking unless you're remind yourself
yourself sometimes you know
yeah I'm not sensitive in that way I
mean people rip on me all the time I go
yeah right you're like that to your
right dude you yeah there's something
about you and you see you have to make
fun of you yeah you know it's so funny
people do it all the time yeah everyone
does but now I think you and also seem
like you want it though it's like you
kind of light you bring it on you know
you want that you want to be kind of
yeah because it doesn't you know growing
up you know as a kid and people used to
call me like you know chopsticks or
whatever right yeah
stinky chopsticks woman stinky yeah or
like they would go or they would come to
make fun of me and I used to come home a
good dad they make fun of me and he
wouldn't give a [ __ ] yeah so you're in
America yeah yep educate you know I'm
the whole thing right yeah and then over
the years you have to figure out a way
to survive because you can't live like
that as a victim Yeah right so then I
you once you accept the fact right and
you grow a little skin and then you
fight back with words right it's fine
then you're able exist in the world I
think and that's when I'm like at the
comedy club clubs in New York it's the
same thing dude when I do radio like
with back in the day when I used to
Norton Patrice all those guys I'd be in
a room with greg Giraldo all those guys
yeah and they would rip me a [ __ ] car
any baby arms little bit undid the whole
[ __ ] thing right it's got my baby
arms right fire boy yeah fire boy right
and the first time I did it with them
I was so sensitive about it Wow but the
next year I went back armed to the teeth
yeah and then they respected me and then
you know so yeah people make funny but
it's not they can't get to me that's
what they can do it yeah you see another
fat Asian yeah you can't go up to him
calm ching-chong yes sure
right they'll get mad right they get
upset and they don't have a handling you
know how to handle it no but I also you
know I don't let strangers do it no like
when if I'm on stage I get off in the
remember and thinks he can talk to me
that way I always go dude no yeah right
I don't know you yeah I mean stop call
me like you know nuprin or whatever you
want to call me a lot of people feeling
too familiar with you especially as a
podcast yes sometimes I get what I what
gets me that I that bugs me I don't like
real drunk people coming and talking to
me because it just makes me feel
uncomfortable they're not gonna remember
it it feels false
it doesn't feel fake I feel like they
have some desire to engage in a chat and
whatever yellow you know but if
somebody's drunk it just makes me feel
like I don't know I don't like it yeah
you funk don't even know why and also
the big big white dudes get aggressive
with me yeah like all I can see that
they come up from behind me and they'll
grab me by the neck and pick me I'm not
kidding here oh yeah
and that's why a lot of times you know
you know you know I want to go out
listen Tiger belly Fran fans the nights
I go out to see the audience is usually
guaranteed the last show which is Sunday
or a Thursday if I'm doing one show I
will go out and I'll take a photo with
every single person that's there right
but the first shows on during the week I
don't do it because I don't want to
cross mingle between the people leaving
the show yeah and the people entering
yeah sometimes you know you're taking
photos after between shows and then
people from the second show will come
and and then you have to do double the
work yeah right and then you do it the
second show and then the same people
they bombarded the first so they come
back you know it's just another drunk
now they want a picture and they want a
drawing of you they just stand there
yeah holding a wine yeah
four of them draw a picture oh yeah it's
definitely it's crazy mad cuz I used to
do a meeting being after every show or
just like you know stand meet with
everyone after the shows and then I just
started I just started to get like
exhaust Silas couldn't mentally even
handle it and so yeah now I have to do
yeah almost like every other show it's a
it's also weird thing do you ever think
this is and I think this all the time
I'm about to go up on stage and you know
the room is sold out or whatever so
there's hundreds of people know they
paid right and the reality sinks into my
head
and I go what the [ __ ] like I don't feel
what they I'm supposed to feel be by
being up there I don't feel like a
headliner I don't feel you know you just
kind of gone wow this is almost
overwhelming do you ever feel that way
yeah I mean it's obviously think about
what you're actually doing right right
like I'm gonna go up there yeah I feel
like it becomes this sort of job it's
just like you know how to do it it's
like clocking in for work a lot of times
yeah you know how to do it sure it's
engaging but it's like it's almost this
alter ego that kind of takes can you
know takes on and then you're able to
engage more as like a human whenever you
get done with doing the job it almost
feels like two separate things a lot of
times that's an interesting when I get
done I'm like glad it's over because
like it's fun and I'm glad I'm able to
help you know be a part of people
laughing yeah but it's also like you
know it's just a lot of it's just a lot
sometimes and I'm just call was just
feel like glad that it's over I never
want to be up there for like those guys
that step there for hours it just seems
so scary insane